gisèle et ses enfants partent en
vacances au guatemala lors de l'escale à
mexico l égard un document et le temps
de récupérer elle rate l'avion il vit
pour acheter trois nouveaux billets pour
se rendre au guatemala mais ce n'est pas
tant elle découvre avec surprise qu'elle
doit aussi racheter trois billets de
retour
car pour sa compagnie aérienne un billet
d'avion c'est un tout vous manquez une
portion du voyage on annule le billet au
complet
c'est ce qu'on appelle dans le jargon
aérien le no show une politique
appliquée par plusieurs transporteurs
aériens pour le savoir avant de réserver
vous devrez vous plonger dans la lecture
des conditions de vente
le fin mot de l'histoire vous réserver
un billet d'avion avec correspondance ou
un billet aller retour
attention si vous ratez un vol c'est
tout le voyage qui pourrait tomber à
l'eau